qu'est-ce que la connexion
la plupart des personnes à qui j'en ai
parlé ont répondu Internet
qui aujourd'hui s'est retrouvé à plus de
5 mètres de son téléphone
visiblement pas grand monde moi aussi
depuis ce matin je l'ai apporté de main
je m'appelle Céline guirardelli je suis
professeure de yoga de danse de ski de
snowboard et de fitness et on m'a
demandé d'intervenir aujourd'hui sur le
thème de la connexion
le téléphone est un outil fabuleux il
crée du lien il nous connecte au monde
moi mon téléphone je l'utilise comme
réveil comme montre comme GPS pour
m'informer et pour aller sur les réseaux
sociaux
grâce à cet outil nous sommes
potentiellement connectés à tout le
savoir ou presque l'humanité a produit
et ce que l'on constate car avec ces
petites choses on sait tout de toi
c'est que nous sommes 61 millions
d'internautes en France dont 53 millions
sur les réseaux sociaux
voici une photo de mes étudiants avant
de commencer un cours de yoga
je constate que nous sommes de plus en
plus connectés vers l'extérieur
être connecté aux autres nous
permettrait de se sentir mieux moins
seul de tourner les autres vers soi de
se sentir au centre de son réseau
et si on se connecte à soi
pour certains cela peut prendre quelques
mois pour ma part ça a été l'histoire de
toute une vie alors j'ai décidé de vous
la raconter
à 23 ans alors que je suis assistante
sociale dans la protection de l'enfance
en banlieue parisienne je décide de
prendre une grande respiration
étant passionné depuis toujours par la
montagne je décide partir faire une
saison d'hiver j'imagine partir 5 mois
puis revenir à Paris je découvre le
snowboard une vraie passion de glisse
comme il n'y a pas de brevet d'état de
snowboard en France je pars passer mon
brevet d'état en Suisse
puis je passe mon brevet à ski et mon
brevet fédéral pour accompagner mes
clients à hors-piste
au lieu de rester 5 mois je reste 15 ans
je crois ne jamais avoir été autant
connecté à moi-même et aux éléments je
ressens une force intérieure face à la
puissance de la montagne mon but faire
du hors-piste me déconnecter de tout
pour me connecter à moi et à la pente
vierge ce que je vais descendre
observe la neige fraîche qui vient de
tomber qui provoque un son sourd qui
étouffe les bruits aux alentours
j'observe les cristaux de neige
sont-ils liés entre eux le manteau
neigeux est-il suffisamment stable le
vent a-t-il créé des accumulations de
neige soufflées la pente que je souhaite
descendre est-elle bien exposée dans
l'instant T dans l'ici et le maintenant
se connecter aux éléments deviennent
question de survie ta vie est en jeu tu
as plutôt intérêt à être bien connecté
avec ce qui t'entoure
ne pas être seul pour faire du
hors-piste et sécurisant en cas
d'accident ou d'avalanche son
coéquipiers peut susceptiblement t'aider
les chances de survie sont sous une
avalanche sont de 15 à 18 minutes
entre 18 et 35 minutes les chances
diminuent à 34%
à Verbier ensuite dans la station dans
laquelle j'enseigne il y a la finale des
championnats du monde sur une montagne
que l'on nomme le bec des Ross
du haut de ses 3223 mètres d'altitude
cette montagne truffée de caillasses
m'inspire grandeur respect désire et
crainte seul je ne l'aurais jamais
descendu mais un jour les conditions se
sont présentées et un ami Julien en qui
jeûne entière confiance m'a proposé de
gravir et de descendre cette montagne à
la montée je réalise que nous sommes en
train d'escalader des falaises en
chaussures de snowboard avec nos
planches de snow accrochées à nos sacs à
dos je ne me sens pas très à l'aise
on nomme les premiers maîtres de la
descente la no folle zone les 300
premiers mètres avoisine en que entre 45
et 50 degrés de pente tu tombes tu
prends le risque de mourir
c'est étonnant car je me suis sentie
pleinement connecté à mon environnement
en même temps pleinement connecté à mon
ami qui me rassure et pleinement
connecté à moi lorsque je me suis
retrouvé seul en haut de cette montagne
car quand tu descends et à chacun de tes
virages tu es seul la pente est si raide
que tu sautes pour tourner
tu entends le bruit de la neige gelée
par endroits se ramollissant par
d'autres puis soudain tu sors de ce long
couloir technique la pente s'ouvre
devant toi et tu commences à enclencher
de long virage avec cette neige fraîche
qui s'éclavousse sur ton visage et qui
crée un grand nuage blanc autour de toi
je ressens un sentiment de liberté
énorme j'ai le sentiment de faire partie
de cette montagne de nous faire plus
qu'un avec elle cette sensation cette
connexion je les ressenti à chacune des
pentes que j'ai descendu
pendant 15 ans cette vie saisonnière m'a
permis de vivre six mois à la montagne
et 6 mois à travers le monde avec mon
sac à dos et mon guide du routard
je rencontre des gens qui vivent au
rythme des saisons et des cycles de la
nature proche de leur terre et je le
sentiment que nous en sommes plutôt des
connectés aujourd'hui
nous veillons voir travaillons bien
après le coucher du soleil
nos immeubles de 10 étages masques le
ciel nous mangeons des tomates et des
courgettes en hiver et nous sommes
davantage connectés à nos téléphones
qu'au rythme du soleil et de la lune
il y a une dizaine d'années je décide de
partir en Inde pour découvrir le yoga à
sa source et là je laisse mon téléphone
de côté pendant plus de deux mois à plus
de 5 mètres
lors de ma formation je me retrouve face
à cet homme se mettre spirituel nommé
yoga
il propose au groupe dont je fais partie
de nous installer assis en tailleur dans
une posture immobile et de placer notre
attention sur notre souffle
au bout de quelques minutes qui me
semble durer des heures je m'agite comme
un asticot je regarde mes voisins qui
semblent immergés dans leur pratique
j'ai l'impression de ne pas avoir bien
compris l'énoncé
alors à la fin de la séance je m'oriente
vers mon maître spirituel et lui demande
je croyais que méditer c'était ne plus
penser
et il me répond
j'en déduis laisse aller la prise
j'insiste je lui demande mais comment et
il me répond tu verras demain
je réalise alors que dès que je ne suis
pas dans l'activité j'entends n'importe
quelle activité le sport que je pratique
l'enseignement voir des gens mes amis ma
famille je pense ou plutôt je ressasse
je n'arrête pas de penser je ne sais pas
me poser en silence pas le silence
extérieur le silence dans mon esprit je
ne sais pas faire taire le train de la
pensée vous savez ce petit train qui
tourne en boucle dans la tête et qui ne
s'arrête jamais
la pensée a besoin d'agir elle l'aime à
s'activer et quelle facilité de plonger
sa main dans sa poche pour atteindre son
téléphone pour occuper le train de la
pensée
si je vous dis de ne pas penser vous
pensez
si je vous dis de ne pas penser à une
vache vous pensez à une vache
le yoga permet d'arrêter le train de la
pensée
yoga en langue indienne le senscrit
signifie
use l'union entre le corps l'esprit et
l'âme
qui 200 ans avant Jésus-Christ à codifié
pour la première fois le yoga sous une
forme écrite et concise il en définit
huit membres 1 les Yamaha ce sont les
préceptes moraux vis-à-vis des autres
la discipline l'honnêteté
la compassion la modération dans les
désirs la non possessivité par rapport
au bien matériel
2 les Niyama ce sont les règles de
discipline individuelle
la pureté le contentement l'étude de soi
l'abandon de soi à quelque chose de plus
grand que soi la nature le cosmos
3 les asanas je découvre et pratique les
postures moi qui avait malmené mon corps
pendant des années avec dix années de
gymnastique rythmique et sportive à haut
niveau de mes 4 ans avec 14 ans suivi de
quinze années de ski et de snowboard au
quotidien pour la première fois de ma
vie je pratique dans le respect de mon
corps
je pratique les salutations au soleil
sorian hamascar sourial le soleil
namascar salué avec respect que l'on
nomme plus communément Namasté
ce sont des enchaînements de posture
saluant le ciel et la terre
ma pratique commence à devenir une
méditation en mouvement
chaque geste est unique lié à ma
conscience ce que je fais ce que je
pense puis ce que je dis devient une
unité une connexion
4 j'apprends à respirer avec ce que la
tradition indienne appelle les pranayama
prana le souffle l'énergie vitale Ayama
l'extension du souffle
ce qui va essayer dans le public c'est
le moment je t'invite à t'installer
confortablement dans ton siège le dos
droit le buste fier la tête humble
merci d'essayer je t'invite à inspirer
et à expirer uniquement par le nez
puis tu peux également placer tes mains
sur ton ventre à l'inspiration tu
gonfles le ventre à l'expiration du
creuse le nombril et le ventre en
direction de ta colonne vertébrale
et enfin si tu le souhaites tu pourras
fermer les yeux une petite minute
pendant que je t'explique les bienfaits
de ta pratique
respirez par le nez permet grâce à tes
cils nasaux de filtrer les impuretés
extérieures
une respiration lente et profonde permet
de purifier ton sang et d'irriguer ton
cerveau ce qui facilite les connexions
entre tes neurones
grâce à ton ventre et ta respiration
abdominale ton diaphragme masse tes
organes ton foie ta rate ton estomac ta
vésicule biliaire
tes poumons acquièrent une plus grande
élasticité tu augmentes le volume et la
pression d'oxygène entrant dans ton
corps ce qui te permet de libérer une
plus grande quantité de dioxyde de
carbone
tu actives ton système nerveux
parasympathique
système nerveux responsable du
relâchement et de la relaxation de ton
corps
encore une respiration profonde
et tu pourras rouvrir les yeux et
observer les effets de ton souffle
tu viens juste de découvrir une infime
partie de ce pranayama de cette énergie
vitale car il existe une multitude de
pranayama
5 pratti rara c'est le contrôle et
l'économie des sens pratique à rein dans
la tradition indienne et comparé à une
tortue repliant ses membres sous sa
carapace une façon de ne pas se laisser
distraire par les sensations externes
sensorielles
6 d'Arana c'est la fixation de la pensée
en un seul point
pour cela tu peux utiliser une bougie
un mantra écouter de la musique
faites
Diana la méditation le pilier qui permet
d'atteindre le Chama dit l'état d'éveil
d'unité la libération l'extase
je pratique ces sutras pendant des
semaines des mois
et au fil des jours je peux enfin
laisser défiler mes pensées
je peux enfin m'installer en posture
assise
immobile en sous casse le plaisir d'être
assis en posture immobile et un jour
entre deux pensées je ne pense plus et
ce court instant devient au fil du temps
de longs moments et j'accepte ce que mon
esprit est prêt à me donner dans
l'instant présent selon les jours selon
les heures j'accepte la situation telle
qu'elle est
la méditation c'est être tout simplement
être ne rien faire aucune action
la méditation transforme elle transforme
vos réactions en réponse
et surtout la méditation et ludique
c'est un jeu car si on se prend au
sérieux et que l'on pense avoir de super
pouvoirs
que l'on nourrit
et dans ce cas on se regarde méditer on
ne médite plus
la méditation c'est l'amusement dans le
moment présent
le yoga c'est l'arrêt de l'activité
automatique du mental
le mental est fait de mots le soi c'est
le silence
c'est la plus belle richesse que j'ai
retenu
et c'est celle aussi que j'offre lors de
mes cours
je pense qu'il est indispensable de se
connecter à notre être véritable à
l'essentiel à son essentiel de se
connecter à notre intuition à nos rêves
à nos aspirations profondes ce qui
permet d'accéder à notre boussole de vie
nos soins sont plus justes nos décisions
sont plus saines ce qui nous permet de
mieux vivre avec les autres et avec soi
à la fin de mon immersion en Inde
j'obtiens un diplôme international pour
enseigner le yoga
je décide d'arrêter les saisons d'hiver
et je rentre à Paris
aujourd'hui j'ai presque 40 ans
je crois avoir trouvé mon compromis de
vie ma connexion
en m'éloignant des sollicitations
extérieures je me suis rapprochée aussi
de mon propre univers
j'ai créé une cellule familiale un bébé
je me sens encore plus en lien avec les
autres
je vais maintenant aller chercher mon
téléphone
et avant de le rallumer je vais prendre
quelques instants pour apprécier le
moment que l'on vient de partager
ensemble quelques instants pour
apprécier les émotions que cela m'a
procuré
j'aimerais finir avec cette citation de
patente jally
quand la périphérie s'apaise le centre
se révèle
merci Namasté
[Applaudissements]